-Squeezie : Les amis bonjour ! bienvenue dans cette vidéo.
-Squeezie : Je suis aujourd'hui avec Carlito et McFly !
-McFly : *Bruit chelou*
-Carlito : *Bruit de corbeau*
-Squeezie : Les amis aujourd'hui on va faire un trucs assez drôle qui as déjà été fait cent-mille fois ....
-Squeezie : Ok ? Parce que vous savez ?...
-McFly : Mais regardez cette vidéo quand même.
-Squeezie : Mais regardez quand même !
-Mcfly : Mais vraiment
Squeezie : Aujourd'hui on va tester les gars notre amitié , on va voir si chacun pense vraiment la même chose de l'autre.
Squeezie : Par exemple je dit, qui aime jouer de la guitare ?
Squezie : Tu me dis ?
-Squeezie et Carlito: McFly!
-Squeezie :C'est bien donc on pense pareil sur McFly !
-Squeezie :Ok les gars on commence :
Qui est le plus apte à ...
- Carlito :Ah ça commence déjà comme ça ?!!!!!!!
*Phrase de Mcfly et Carlito inaudible*
- Carlito :On s'est même pas maquillés !!!!!
*Bruit de coup de poing*
-Squeezie :Premièrement, qui est le plus apte à pleurer en publique ?
-Carlito : 3
*rire aigus*
-McFly :Oh oui Oh
-Squeezie : *phrase inaudible*
Eh mais moi, j'suis pas un fragile !
*pleurs de bébés*
-Squeezie : Qui est le plus apte à oublier les anniversaires ?
Qui est le plus apte à oublier les anniversaires ?
-Squeezie : Ah !
Ah tu t'es auto shamer toi
-Carlito : Ah, tu t'es auto-shamer (auto-citer), toi !
-Mcfly : Ouai mais je suis le pire à ça.
-Squeezie : Moi aussi !
-Mcfly : T'as une anecdote horrible pour les anniversaires? Par exemple moi je ne connais pas l'anniversaire de ma mère
-Mcfly : Tu veux une anecdote horrible sur les anniversaires, par exemple moi je ne connais pas l’anniversaire de ma mère !
*blanc*
-Carlito surpris : Il connait pas l'anniversaire de sa mère !
-Squeezie : Eh balance pas toi t'es qui toi !!!
-Squeezie : Ok les gars, qui est le plus apte à être bourré?
Qui est le plus apte à être bourré?
3, 2, 1... *rire de Carlito*
-Carlito : Ah il a déjà montré.
3, 2, 1
-Carlito: Regarde ces trois visages.
-Carlito : Alors primo pour toute la communauté, l'abus d'alcool est dangereux pour la santé
Et ensuite ces derniers temps je bois beaucoup moins, ce qui est pire quand je bois du coup
-Mcfly : Ah oui là c'était chaud, la dernière fois, ça faisait des années que je ne t'avais pas vu comme ça
-Carlito : Ouais il y a pas de souci on enchaîne j'ai vomis dans mon taxi
-Squeezie : *rires* Ok.. T'as vomis dans le taxi?
-Carlito : Comment?
-Squeezie : Naaaaaan
-Mcfly : Allez on y va il arrivait même pas à ouvrir la porte de chez lui c'est sa femme qui me l'a dit
-Mcfly : Allez on y va!
*claquement de main et rires*
*musique triste*
-Squeezie : Qui est le plus apte à être fatigué?
*rires*
-Mcfly : Oh il a tout mis tout le monde!
-Mcfly : Nan mais c'est vrai qu'on est...
-Squeezie : Un lundi sur deux on est mort tous les trois on va arrêter!
-Mcfly : On a des vies difficiles vous savez... On fait des vidéos sur youtube, on fait des vidéos à la-
-Squeezie : Nan mais c'est vrai. Moi je trouve que ce métiers est difficile! Difficile!
-Carlito : C'est dur! t'imagines, on fait des vidéos sur youtube, on rigole entre potes, on a aucune censure!
-Squeezie : On fait plus de montage!
-Carlito :On est plutôt bien rémunérés
-Les trois : Oh oh oooh!
-Mcfly : Parfois je me lève à 10 h 30!
-Squeezie : *hurlement*
-Carlito : Oh nan ! C'est DUR notre vie!
-Squeezie : Qui est les plus apte à être impatient?
*rires*
-Mcfly : T'avais un message à faire passer peut-être à ton pote?
-Carlito : T'es bien patient surtout quand avec ta jambe tu fais ça
Et que tu fais ça
Et que tu te ronges les ongles
Nan c'est cool !
-Mcfly : Eh dis je suis patient hein!
*rires*
-Squeezie : Qui est... alors celle la elle était nulle je vous préviens d'avance
Qui est le plus apte à tomber quand il marche?
-Mcfly : Attends attends bonjour
-Carlito : Alors en vrai ...
-Squeezie: Aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaah !
-Carlito: Écoutez-moi bien, j'ai un problème d'oreille interne...
... pour le skate, le sky, les rollers, je peux pas faire de virage à gauche.
Ce qui est un vrai soucis
-McFly: Faut faire trois virages à droite!
-Carlito: Mon osthéo, elle me dit : "Attends attends, mets-toi juste debout..."
-Squeezie : AHAH, c'est génial
Mec, elle me dit mets-toi debout, et je faisais ça...
... Donc elle m'a dit y'a un petit truc, y'a un petit truc.
-Squeezie, tu peux te mettre debout ?
-Carlito: Sans exagérer, hein ?
Mcfly et Squeezie : Wooooaww !!!! C'est puissant !
Voila, du coup, j'ai parfois j'ai le vertige debout !
*rires moqueurs *
-Carlito: C'est cool en tous cas des bons potes qui se marrent pas mais qui prennent soins...
-Squeezie: Est-ce que tu peux demander au couloir peut être on va voir si y a des rires.
-Carlito: Excusez moi j'ai une question! Est-ce que la phrase "J'ai le vertige debout vous fait rire"?
-Squeezie: Ah ils sont morts de rires, ils sont morts de rires!
-McFly: Bah oui c'est normal.
*Carlito rage*
*rires*
-Squeezie: Qui est le plus apte à rire au mauvais moment?
-Squeezie: Ouiiiiii !
-McFly: J'ai vraiment cette image de con...
-Carlito: Bah t'es un peu con con!
-McFly: ouai chui un peu... Remarque en même temps regarde le visage.
-Squeezie: Qui est le plus apte à péter en publique?
-Carlito s'adresse à Squeezie: Toi tu pètes régulièrement, tes pets on dirais des points virgules.
ensuite à Mcfly : Toi tu es un buffle.
-McFly: Ouai non mais moi...
-Carlito: Tu es un buffle!
*Bruit de pet*
-Squeezie: J'aimerais qu'on parle de ce qui c'est passé ce matin au réfectoire stp.
-Carlito: "réfectoire"
-Carlito : Excusez moi !!
-Mcfly:  Je t'empris, non mais vas y il a raison
-Carlito: Est ce que quelqu'un dis encore réfectoire en 2017 ?
-Mcfly : eh non, beh non mais non on le savait
-Carlito : ouais ouais c'est ce que je pensais
Squeezie: bon alors les gars, qui est le plus aptes à être un flurt pour les filles ?
-Carlito : ah bah vous êtes
-Squeezie : Oh...
-Carlito: Vous êtes très gentils
-Mcfly : Mais je te trouve très beau Raphael
Carlito : ça c'est ça le désir c'est ça l'interprétations du désir
carlito: c'est bon non mais les gars. vous avez du désir pour moi là?
Mcfly: ah oui
s<ueezie: ah mais viens là
squeezie: ah oui  ahhhhhhh
Carlito: stoooop
Mcfly: pardon
squeezie: qui est le plus aptes à pleurer devant un film triste
Squeezie: ah ah je crois queeee....
mcfly: ah  bah oui  bah le mec est con et fragile
Mycfly c'est ça l'image que vous avez de moi
Carlito: mais mec
Squeezie: Mais mcfly enfinnn
Mcfly:*bruit de pleure*
Carlito: mais c'est très bien d'etre sensibles
Carlito: c'est pas un défaut d'etre sensibles
squeezie: Les femmes adorent les hommes sensibles
Mcfly: ouais mais
Carlito: moi! vous avez mis moi!!
Mcfly: non
Carlito: Si t'as mis moi
Mcfly:ah oui je me suis gourés je voulais mettrre moi aussi
Bruits de rires
Carlito: moi je pleure je pleure devant des séries genre "this is us"Je chiale
Squeezie: Ah ouais moi jai pleuré devant saw
Carlito: ouais mais ça c un peuuuu, tu pleures devant des films qui font pas pleurer
le suspens et le pleur je crois que tu...
Est-ce que t'as pleuré devant ça
Bah bien sur
Ouai, il ya un problème là
Vous avez pas pleuré devant paranormal activity
Non
C'est pas trop triste
Imagine j'te fait AAAAAAAAH
*pleure*
Non vraiment c'est bizzare
Ok et si je te dis qu'on va plus travailler dans le bureau d'à côté
*rires*
T'imagines dans un film aller maintenat tu me fais la peur
Y'as un énorme monstre qui arrive et qui prend ta fille devant tes yeux
Qui est le plus apte à parler aux animaux
Bah oui tu sais, avec le petit chien, le petit shiba, le petit délire un peu d'internet
Je vais vous dire j'ai besoin de votre aide
Je me suis acheté 2 poissons rouges
Oui je sais c'est la pire chose
Ma fille voulait trop et je lui ai acheté mais j'ai pas encore trouver de noms
Findus
Ouais mais il y en a 2
Croustibat
*rires*
C'est les meilleurs noms
N'hésitez pas à nous appeler on résout vos problèmes en live
Qui est le plus apte à  se marier à une célébrité
est ce qu'on prend en consideration le fait qu'on est pas célibataire
ou on est dans un discours absolu  dans l'absolution de la neutralité
*fait une autre voix* Je m'appelle Jean-Michel, bonjour, bienvenue dans mon émission
je suis chiant.fm
Bonjour en quoi constite votre émission expliquer nous
Alors cette émission doit être le plus chiant possible
Jean-Michel Chiant bonjour vous allez bien
Oh cousi-cousa ça dépend du temps
Non vous mélangez tout, je vous pose des questions simples vous répondez simplement
Par exemple ça c'est de quelle couleur
Tout dépend du
ça ne dépend pas
Quel est le chiffre qui vient après 2
ça dépend si vous comptez les décimals
Bien evidemment si il ya les décimals
Quel est votre sexe, vous êtes du sexe masculin ou féminin
Squeezie : Alors on a pas répondu
Squeezie : Qui est le plus apte à se marier à une célébrité ?
Squeezie : Moi ?
Squeezie : Ben tu sais quoi juste pour me prouver que vous avez tord, je me priverais toute ma vie de sortir avec une fille connu
McFly : C'est con parce que y'avais emily ratajkowski qui viens de m'écrire
Squeezie : Qui serais le plus apte à mourir en premier en cas d'invasion zombie ?
Squezzie : Oh les salopes vous avez mis moi ?
Carlito : Ben mec babtou fragile qu'est ce tu veux
Mcfly: La vérité en plus avec tes skills sur gaming ça se trouve t'aurais pû échaffauder une technique
Carlito : Ouais mais un vrai zombie tu le tue pas avec une manette , allez tiens
Squeezie : Qui serais le plus apte à  être un drama king ?
Squeezie : C'est vrai ?
McFly : Bah oui mec c'est horrible
McFly : J'ai toutes les réponses ou ça chiale et ou c'est con
Carlito : Tu comprend à travers les réponses à ces questions à quel point chui doux avec toi parce que pfffff....
....
Carlito : Nan c'était un peu brute